so if i were to recommend the absolute
best food for anti-aging it would be
eggs but especially the egg yolks okay
out of all my skype interviews that i do
with these amazing before and afters the
common food that most people consume
would be eggs pasture-raised organic
eggs there's a certain compound in eggs
called
phosphatidylcholine which is really
important in slowing down the breakdown
of the cellular membranes also to help
support things like hepatitis a
hepatitis c hepatitis b
it's great for dementia memory loss and
it's really a shame that as people get
older they're told to avoid eggs eggs
are one thing that you're you don't have
to worry about restricting there really
is no side effect from a good
pasture-raised organic egg if you're
doing intermittent fasting in the keto
program definitely include eggs in your
plan and you do not have to worry about
them at all in fact they're going to
help you greatly